termina La tregua de fin de año y vuelve
las manifestaciones a Perú al menos 10
sindicatos de izquierda y agrupaciones
civiles salieron nuevamente a las calles
para manifestar su apoyo al expresidente
Pedro Castillo exigir la renuncia de la
presidenta Dina boluarte y elecciones
anticipadas entre otras demandas
queremos que se cierre el congreso y
también que haya pronta solución porque
nos afecta bastante esta situación que
está pasando nos solidarizamos también
con los familiares Que luchando sus
hijos han perdido sus padres y han
quedado familias abandonadas el Primer
Ministro Alberto tal hora defendió el
derecho de los ciudadanos a la protesta
pero demandó que predominara la calma en
las muestras de descontento en alusión a
las casi tres decenas de muertes que
resultaron de los choques con las
fuerzas del orden en las manifestaciones
de diciembre las protestas afectaron
fundamentalmente las regiones de puno y
cusco allí se vivieron bloqueos que
afectaron el turismo y el comercio los
33 peruanos queremos vivir en paz
queremos la libertad de tránsito
queremos
transitar libremente comprar vender
visitar a nuestros familiares
transportar nuestros productos y esto es
especialmente importante en una
localidad como puno que vive del
comercio es una región de emprendedores
entonces con esta
situación volvemos a hacer un llamado a
las a los que están protestando en este
momento a respetar la vida y la
integridad de nuestros compatriotas ante
esta situación los ministros de defensa
e interior junto a la jefa de estado
instalaron un centro de seguimiento y
control de crisis las movilizaciones
reiniciaron horas después de que miles
de personas opositoras a Castillo
protagonizaran una marcha por la paz y
la tranquilidad en medio de los
contratiempos políticos que atraviesa el
país